last month misha renee went on tick-tock
asking the world to help her find this
mystery man she met in miami in august
but things got messy when the world
collectively found out
who he really is
eight million people watched misha
renee's tick tock with the caption
saying quote tic-tock help me find this
man i met in miami he walked right in
the ocean to introduce himself to me i
was lit when he gave me his number i'm
counting on y'all hopefully he ain't
married the only reason i did it is
because i was on tick tock and i seen
the popular trend that was helped me
find him it was just simply just to
reconnect it wasn't anything more oh but
he is married for six years in fact with
four kids i tracked him down this
mystery man is aiden giles from the
detroit area he had no idea the video
was posted at first it was his wife
cherie who said somebody text her about
the video we just immediately started
arguing because i started immediately
started cussing them out like
bro you really got me messed up and i
kept asking did you sleep with her he
said no so she messages misha directly i
said did you sleep with him she said
nobody literally only met at the beach
and that was it
you see his
face that's what i said like you know i
was lying i know i didn't lie that's
what i told her i didn't see my ticket i
didn't get a chance to
so i'm like
well you looking for him this hard
obviously it was something to y'all
she's like is that your man i said not
no more not even anymore
and then she was like um if you don't
mind me asking like who are you i said
that's my husband i like how the
original tick tock she went hopefully he
ain't married
which goes to show you
how often mary news is doing shady [ __ ]
of course yeah of course hopefully he
ain't married
the lie detector determined
that was a lie she says misha apologized
immediately and their messages saying
quote sis i'm sorry i had no clue
something would happen
i wish the best for you and your kids i
won't be reaching out to him i told her
i'm like says you can help i'm good can
you not delete the video i don't want
him lying about this too
it was disrespectful was it cheating no
it was not cheating
but it was this rece
i didn't do it about me
you know what this is like what this is
a man who did something wrong but he's
trying to get off the like the the he's
trying to get off on a technicality well
the thing that happened is that it
looked it looked bad
it looked it looked hella look it's a
sus
that looks us but it don't mean that
some [ __ ] happened but it looks like i
can understand it's hard it's hard can i
ask you something how to get out of bed
you go to the beach you're talking to a
girl you go introduce yourself to her
and what circumstances are you giving a
woman your number when you're married i
understand what you're saying right
unless it's business
what business are you doing shirtless at
the beach going up to strangers listen i
like to be your shirtless i didn't ask
you that what business are you doing at
the beach shirtless going up to random
people i'm about to be streamless right
now
no you're at the beach
i'm not saying i'm trying to say this
i was born at night i was not born last
night okay
don't get it no no no no i'm not getting
into it at all i don't i don't know like
i said it's sus
it's not suss that's a smoking gun
that's a smoking gun yeah you got a
knife in your hand blood dripping off of
it there's a body on the floor yeah i'm
not saying i saw you kill it but i mean
the circumstantial evidence is
overwhelming am i come on bro does the
glove nah listen i'm just flipping it if
it's if it's my girl i found out she at
the beach running up to random [ __ ]
giving her numbers and she she out here
introducing herself to them
come on i'm not stupid
i'm not
yo get miss me with that [ __ ]
oh she can go
she can go
yeah that's crazy that because listen to
me it's not even
were you successful is where you trying
it's not did you do it no were you
trying to do then get caught
no you just didn't get to succeed
that's what you're saying right
because i if if we cut you on camera
being this stupid
and trying to get this girl's number
what were you doing when the camera's
worn yes yes yes yes yes you get what
i'm saying yeah cause this is brazen and
stupid chick this is
you don't start here flagrant you don't
start here you don't say one day i'm
going to the beach shirtless going up to
a random girl to give your number you've
done something else sneaky yeah
sneaky link
he's like he's trying so hard to get off
on this technique because aydah you know
everybody is looking and you know not
only you're a good looking guy you got
the month of miami muscles and you
hugging her tight and so everybody is
looking at that i know and and that's
it sucked because i knew the video
looked so bad and i told her i wish i
could put you in that moment because it
was nothing like the video made it look
from her point of view she said that
you asked her for her phone number and
invited her after and then she also said
that um
she lost your number and that's why she
looked to tick-tock to try to fight
yeah honestly no she didn't have my
number
she didn't even have my real name
i didn't even know they were recording
either so that threw me weight off
that's not good that you said that
that's not good that you i didn't know
that it was recording cause i don't know
yeah i mean
that's not good that you said that bro
but hey you know what he didn't give her
a real name he didn't give her a real
number
so let's find out why he was in this
situation to begin with ladies you could
put a four in the chat if you agree with
what i'm about to say
guys sometimes y'all stink okay you
don't even know it and let me tell you
women really appreciate it when you come
smelling like
what is don't matter the ladies know put
a four right when you smell good they
appreciate that and that's where today's
sponsor comes in scent bird scent bird
is a subscription-based service that
allows you to try a new fragrance every
single month that you choose
so you want to go up with prada you want
to be out there with the gucci wanna be
out or whatever it doesn't matter you
can get the high quality colognes out
there at your door the thing about
high-end colognes is that they're
expensive you want to buy a bottle can
cost anywhere from 150 to 600 bucks so
with scentbird you get these great
samples that last you more than a month
and then at that point you could try it
on see if you really rock with it and
then from that point if you want to get
a full one you can or you can switch the
next fragrance and keep switching out
your scents so you keep it fresh you
feel me you come in these really cool
cylinders that are super easy to use you
just pop it up here boom
that's it soup
super easy to use okay uh and i actually
got two of them i got one from versace
and one from dolce kabana one's called
eros and the other one is called um
which is a little bit of french suave
if you use our promo code you get 55 off
your first month is just gonna cost you
seven bucks
all right sheree you rolling your eyes
because it's hard to say you don't you
don't know someone's recording you and
you posing for a camera
i posted a picture i didn't pause the
camera
don't look at me like that
pose for the picture yeah
because in the pit and the pit was an
innocent pig i feel like it was in this
i understand what you're saying i'm not
even about to get back on that topic so
yeah she kicked me over the head i get
it it was disrespectful for my marriage
and my wife i get it but in my head as a
man i'm kind of like it was so little
and innocent like hey it wasn't nothing
like that sheree says it took weeks to
figure things out and truly understand
what happened that day i know what type
of man i married i didn't marry a
cheater i would have never married him
if he was a cheater
but after talking to my parents and
praying with them and just trying like
wrapping my mind around and i kept
saying like i don't want to make an
emotional decision
just
oh it's a permanent decision of
temporary emotions sheree realizing how
a nine second video on tick tock can
change everything she and aiden will be
starting counseling next week did you
suggest the marriage counseling because
of this situation or would you have
chosen to do this if this didn't happen
this situation it definitely it broke
the trust i have for him so i suggested
it aiden what have you learned what have
you learned sir oh the number one thing
if you are a married man please keep
women six feet away from you on any
beach possible okay i want
um
other couples and married couples just
to see how all this unfold whatever
y'all go through if y'all strong enough
y'all can get through
okay let me
let me
you want to put god first
you listen you know what if she wants to
stay with the man she wants to do this
after counseling i got no issue with him
it's your marriage you stay for it for
whatever you want right till death do
you part for some people that that
entails a lot man okay
what's the matter i'm trying to see it
from his perspective okay in what
circumstances are you married
were you going up to random women at the
beach
hugging up on them
exchanging names and numbers
and if you didn't exchange if you didn't
give her your number if you didn't
really give her your name he didn't do
all that stuff
why is your wife mad at you then because
of how it looks and makes her look
that's what she's mad because that's how
it makes her look you don't want nobody
you don't want everybody to holler at
you about some [ __ ] you didn't know
about your man right oh [ __ ] that's what
you be doing when i'm not there and you
don't want if if you if you want to
catch [ __ ] you want to catch
them yourself it's like [ __ ] up that
other people
tell you the feeling is wack right in
the santo that's why she's mad there's
multiple reasons why she's mad right oh
other people are telling me what you're
doing that's [ __ ] that that that's that
i can understand i get what you say
mm-hmm i understand that okay if i'm out
at the club yeah okay someone comes up
to me we're having a conversation
someone's feeling that then it video
viral video goes out okay i didn't do
nothing she came up to me at the club
were just having a conversation or
remember like hey i like the way you
dance whatever okay the video goes viral
my wife comes to me and says
what the [ __ ] was you doing oh yeah i
thought
ralph looked good i told him that's it
did you give her a number no i didn't
did you give your name and all that
stuff i told my name does nothing is it
well you broke my trust
i think i'ma be pissed
of course cause i didn't do nothing yeah
i didn't do nothing
and if you think i did when i'm telling
you i did it then we got a bigger issue
fair
what happened here
is something more within whatever their
dynamic is you get what i'm saying yeah
that's what you're saying it shouldn't
just be because like you are seen with
opposite sex it
and that that's all it takes it's more
than that
that's what i'm talking about
is that who is not okay it's just a big
picture okay right okay it's not just
the fact that he was seen with another
girl
there's a other element what is it well
first and foremost you you you just in
your bathing suit and you're approaching
women with the body you got
it plays in the mana you have to think
about they like a woman
and then after that not only that they
are holding hands why are you holding
two hands like that this is not about
chat this is not salsa this is not
kizomba why are you holding hands like
that you're not
you're not doing that that's not the
context right right but that's where i
would know better if i'm in a
relationship or i'm with a woman yeah
ain't no way i'm not you're grinding on
somebody like this so casually like in
in that in the senate it doesn't make
any sense
it doesn't make sense to do that with
strangers you know what i'm saying like
i couldn't understand why he would be in
that circumstance unless you was trying
right i i'm if i'm going to the beach
and i'm i'm with somebody i don't know
where i'm going to random women hugging
up on them that's crazy right
so to me him sitting there like it
wasn't like that it was innocent it's
like brav nothing about that looks
innocent no no
you would give me the best explanation i
don't i
that's o.j simpson right there yeah
you're gonna have a hard time explaining
that [ __ ] so to me that's why i think he
just got caught he's trying to try to
trying to come back from it as far as
staying with him hey man shout out to
her that's what she wants to do that's
her business but she got caught because
there's no way that she's not she got
caught before some [ __ ] happened come on
bro it's just fine come on bro you was
definitely out there being shaped
there's no way you wasn't so this whole
like see i didn't we didn't do nothing
like yeah but you was hoping to and on
top of that you're not a celebrity so
you're definitely not expecting all this
heat you know all this thing all this
all this wave on you you know i mean for
something that that you're you're not a
celebrity you're just some dude so
you're definitely not thinking you're in
that light yeah and then [ __ ]
decides to put you in that light that's
crazy yeah i'm just thinking about a
circumstance where i'm at the beach and
i go to a random one
maybe you guys in the comments have a
theory maybe this is okay comment
section we're gonna need help you guys
need to give me a valid theory as to why
this guy may have ran up on a random
woman getting all that huggy
touchy-feely with her introduce himself
did all that stuff please explain to me
why a man would do that maybe i'm i'm
missing this i want y'all to help me out
all right watch people are going to go
with
crazy
crazy tensions they're going to say
they're going to no they're all going to
say he's cheating
this this crowd cheating i would dump
him both death we're done
yeah go back to miami when you come back
i packed your [ __ ] and i keyed your car
yo write one if you're done
yeah
one's everywhere
yeah let us know in the comments below
what you guys think